hello everyone the story of Harry Nelson
Pillsbury is a spectacular one he
learned to play chess when he was
already 16 years old and by the time he
was 18 and this was in 1890 he could
already defeat the world champion
Wolfenstein is he defeated him in a
match of three games
the result was two to one in Pillsbury's
favor and okay even though
steinitz did give him the odds of a pawn
but as he was definitely the strongest
player in the United States and well the
Brooklyn chess club paid for his paid
for his trip to go to Hastings and to
the great Hastings tournament of 1895
and a lot of people throughout history
said that this was the the greatest
tournament ever held in that era even
Garry Kasparov says so in his famous
book me and my predecessors and this was
is the tournament where Stein it's
played his famous game against against
what's the guy's name
Bartoli but yeah I would Stein it's
against Bartoli banned the Battle of
Hastings or as I like to call it the the
bravest rope in chess history and there
were a lot of strong players here you
had Chinese their world champion
Emmanuel Lasker you had children you had
tirage Janos quiche left there and
plenty of strong players there were
actually 22 players in the entire
tournament and Harry Nelson Pillsbury
actually won the tournament he was I
think have a point ahead of ahead of
sugaring and full point ahead of
emmanuel ask her
so definitely quite a guy and he also
had this amazing memory he could like if
you showed him like 20 or 30 words
really weird words he could remember
them all and repeat them forward and
backwards and I will put those some of
the words in the description below and I
can't even read most of those words and
he could like look at them and repeat
him with no problem even even the other
day he could repeat him so yeah I mean
I'm I always remember when I read about
Pillsbury and some chess books that I
have what an extraordinary person he was
and it was only due to his illness and
poor health that he never got the
challenge the world champion for the
championship title but he did he did
kind of he didn't invent d4 of course
but he was the first person who used it
in a tournament of this strength and won
the tournament so it was only after his
victory yeah using one d4 that d4 was
actually considered to be a serious move
to be played to be played in in a strong
tournament but this game I have prepared
for you is Harry Nelson Pillsbury
against the Emmanuel Lasker and this so
isn't from the Hastings Tournament this
game was played in 1904 so this was two
years before Pillsbury died so let's see
this game toast burry of course played
d4 we have d5 by Lasker c4 we have E six
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 this is some
sort of a it's the Queens gambit
declined we have Knight to f3 c 5 we
have Bishop to g5 the semi Terra
C capture Sundy for Queen capture son d4
and Knight to c6 attacking the Queen
we have Bishop captures on f6 now
attacking blacks Queen and hero Lasker
played G captures on f6 and it's okay
you can't really capture the Queen here
and go for this rook on a 1 because if
Knight captures on d4 then simply better
capture some d8 and after a night to see
to check King to d2 you do grab the rock
Knight captures anyone but simply Bishop
to h4 and well white will grab this
Knight very soon and he will have 2
nights for a rook which is pretty
awesome
so after Bishop captures on f6 olestra
replied G captures and s6 and we have
Queen to h4 getting the Queen out of
atom out of harm's way we have D
captures on c4 and rook to d1
now attacking Alaska's Queen Bishop to
d7 now we have III and Knight to e5 we
have Knight captures on e5 f captures on
e5 and now Queen captures on c4 of
course both very didn't want to exchange
Queens and here Alaska gets an idea he
will develop his queen with a
Queen to b6 and attack this B to pawn
and this will give him time to develop
as a white defense this pawn and he'll
be okay
but Ellsbury gets a gets a better idea
he plays Bishop to e2 and he he says
okay grab might be to point if you think
this will be important for the game last
/ of course grabs it Queen captures and
b2 pillsbury castles and we have roped
the c8 attacking the Queen and Queen to
b3 and already this is move 15 and the
pillsbury is threatening Queen captures
and e7 would checkmate so Alaska defense
tests he plays rook to c7 and we have
Knight to e4 again with a horrible
threat of Knight to f6 check winning a
piece here at least so defending at
Bishop to e7 and we have Knight to d6
check and the King to f8 if Oscar were
to capture this night with Bishop
captures on d6 then Queen captures on d6
and this is threatening to capture the
rook the rook cannot move as this Bishop
will be hanging and the Queen has to
help with the defense of the roof so
Queen to b6 and now simply Queen
captures on e5 and this is what a temple
on the rook and well the material is
equal so Laster didn't really achieve
anything but this screen capture some b2
so after Knight to d6 check Alaska
decided okay King to f8 we have Knight
to c4 now attacking the Queen on b2 and
lots replace going to be 5 getting out
of the way and also defending this hard
earth earned pawn and pillsbury isn't
interested in regaining this material
advantage plays at 4 and well the threat
is to open up bf file for so an
additional piece can attack the King
last replace it captures on f4 and we
have Queen to d4 now centralizing the
Queen also with the tempo on the rook on
h8 we have to have six and now Queen
captures on f4 and we have Queen to c5
and here pillsbury starts an amazing
attack he plays Knight to e5 and of
course this Knight cannot be captured as
the world the point is pinned so we have
a bishop te 8 we have Knights to g4 now
and here lasker plays f5 and the last
sir cannot allow Pillsbury to capture
this f6 point if you if you were to play
something like route to g8 then simply
Knight captures on f6 we have Bishop
captures on f6 and Queen captures on f6
would check and have to work to have
seven Queen captures on e6 and this is
much better for white so after Knight to
g4 Alaska like I said decided to go for
f5 and here we have Queen to h6 check
King to f7 and now a beautiful move by
Pillsbury he plays Bishop to c4 with a
double attack here on the east sex pawn
and of course the bishop is immortal if
last word captured and simply nice to e5
check for King the king and queen so
after Bishop to c4 last chord plays rook
the rook to c6 now defending that eastex
pawn and well he can defend against
everything so pillsbury simple played
rogue captures and i fight what to check
and now again we're gonna attack on the
king and the Queen and the rook has to
be captured we have Queen captures rook
and now rock to f1 so post Murray gives
up two rooks for the Queen but as you'll
see this is quite winning so we have
Queen captures on f1 team captures on f1
and Bishop to d7 Laster is making room
for his King to safely get away but
Pillsbury does not allow this he plays
Queen to h5 check and after King to g8
he plays Knight to e2 e5 and this is
attacking the rook and also the bishop
on d7 but none of those matter as White
has a forced checkmate in six moves so
any move black plays it's either made in
6 or less so the best defense will be
King to g7 and now the king is
intimating net Queen f7 check King h6
tonight to g4 check King g5 Queen to g7
check King h4 a knight to f6 threatening
Queen to g4 check so Bishop captures
Queen captures with check and after King
h5 Bishop to e2 checkmate
but it never got to this because after
this very
nice Knight to e5 move less or resigned
the game so yeah it's it's a definitely
beautiful game and a beautiful example
of how how the early masters used e4 to
crush their opponents in this champion
how to crush world champions so yeah
that's it for this video I do hope you
enjoyed it and for those of you who only
hear about Harry Nelson pillsbury for
the first time I am very pleased to
introduce him to you and yeah I would
like to thank Vince oshina Barry
Keith Cunningham and Mickey Alba Celaya
for contributions to my channel I really
appreciate it and since the month of
August is behind us I would also like to
thank everyone who contributed to my
channel in the month of August you've
made this entire youtube experience
extremely extremely easy for me and i
mean it's it's sometimes it's hard work
but it definitely helps you know when
any of you contributed you always wrote
me a nice message and it was it was
beautiful
I'll put it like that so yeah thank you
everyone and as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank y'all for
watching and I will see you soon